seit dem wochenende beschäftigt ich uns
auch ein ganz anderes thema und 2d
krawallnacht von frankfurt die ganz
ähnliche züge zu der in stuttgart vor
wenigen wochen hatte in der nacht auf
sonntag eskalierte eine erste ruhige
partie auf dem opernplatz bei der zu
beginn 3000 menschen ungefähr feierten
und diese erschreckenden bilder
erreichten uns dann von der nach das
soll zuerst eine gruppen schlägerei
gegeben haben zwischen 25 bis 30
menschen und dann als die polizei kam
eskalierte die situation
die polizei wurde von hunderten der
jugendlichen angegriffen mit flaschen
beworfen
man sprach sogar von einem flaschen
hagel bei mir im studio ist jetzt uwe
schönemann der ehemalige innenminister
von niedersachsen nehmen wenn sie solche
bilder sehen was geht in ihnen vor
es ist einfach unbegreiflich dass so
eine gewalt gegenüber polizeibeamten
ausgeübt wird ich selber kenne das noch
aus der szene in göttingen linksautonome
oder eben bei castor-transporten aber
hier ist es so dass ja tatsächlich auch
zuschauer jubeln wenn polizisten
getroffen werden durch steine und
anderes und das ist eine
gewalteskalation die muss uns
nachdenklich machen und da müssen wir
wirklich sehen dass wir das in den griff
bekommen es ist jetzt leider nicht das
erste mal dass so was passiert vor allem
jetzt in der korona zeit immer wieder
als grund wurde angeführt dass die
jungen leute eben nicht mehr feiern
gehen kann man kann sich nur noch
draußen treffen
sehen sie als auch als einen der
hauptgründe warum es jetzt immer mehr zu
solchen aktionen kommt wenn man sich den
polizeipräsidenten aus frankfurt genau
anhört dann ist das sicherlich
unterschiedlich zu bewerten einmal ist
es so eine szene von jugendlichen die
einfach sich die einfach feiern wollen
aber es sind eben auch viele mit
migrationshintergrund und ich glaube das
ist der hauptpunkt worum wir uns jetzt
kümmern müssen zu sehen wer sind die
täter
warum machen sie das und insofern eine
anja studie die eigentlich offen licht
wie polizei gewalt gegen polizisten sich
entwickelt das ist wichtig denn nur wenn
wir wissen wer die täter sind kann man
eben zum beispiel auch
integrationsprogramme dann auch schalten
das ist der entscheidende punkt sind sie
der meinung dass die polizeibeamten
überhaupt genug ausgerüstet
darauf vorbereitet sind auch so viel
hass und gewalt von solch großen gruppen
die polizei ist wirklich exzellent
ausgebildet einmal sind das ja
bachelorabsolventen die auch gerade
theoretisch auf solche dinge dann auch
vorbereitet werden aber es wird auch
richtig trainiert systemische
einsatztraining wo man genau auf solche
situationen vorbereitet wird und
insofern ist das sicherlich schwer
auszuhalten für die polizisten und
polizisten aber es ist sicherlich so
dass die polizisten eigentlich damit
umgehen können
die 39 menschen die festgenommen worden
sind es 38 männer und eine frau am
samstag in der nacht wurden mittlerweile
alle wieder freien fuß gesetzt sind die
strafen in deutschland ihrer meinung
nach zu lasch hätten diese menschen
jetzt sowieso schöner haft bleiben
müssen wie geht unser rechtssystem
momentan mit solchen angriffen um die
konkreten fall kann ich natürlich nicht
beurteilen aber ich finde man muss die
strafe sofort auf die tat folgen lassen
wenn man erst zwei eu haft kommt aber
nach 24 stunden wieder frei ist und
vielleicht irgendwann mal in einigen
monaten vor gericht kommt wenn überhaupt
dann ist hat das keine abschreckende
wirkung ich glaube bei solchen größeren
veranstaltungen muss man relativ schnell
staatsanwaltschaft richter dabei haben
die sich das möglichst auch noch selber
angucken und da muss innerhalb von tagen
meistens auch das urteil gesprochen
werden
das ist das einzige was natürlich wirkt
aber es ist eine gesellschaftliche
debatte die wir in dem zusammenhang auch
brauchen und die anerkennung für die
polizei ist meiner ansicht nach in der
vergangenheit nicht so gewesen wie es
eigentlich notwendig ist und daher
glaube ich ansetzen
natürlich haben wir gerade auch durch
die sozialen medien sehr viel fake news
um nur ein beispiel in dem zusammenhang
zu nennen
und dann finde ich es natürlich sehr
bedauerlich wenn gerade auch
repräsentanten der politik auch hohe
repräsentanten wie die bundesvorsitzende
essen dann einfach die polizei unter
generalverdacht stellt und wenn man sich
vorstellt dass ja teilweise auch
migrantinnen und migranten aus staaten
kommen wo eigentlich die polizei nicht
demokratisch ist dann fühlen sie sich im
prinzip angestachelt dann vielleicht
sogar tätig zu werden und da muss man
das wort in dem zusammenhang von der
höheren politik auch abwägen und das ist
natürlich genau das falsche signal
jetzt haben sie ein paar maßnahmen
erwähnt die helfen würden eine studie
damit dass sein integrationskurse
projekte geben kann schnellere
rechtsprechung denken sie trotzdem biss
sich all das geändert hat bis man das
vielleicht implementiert hat müsse damit
rechnen dass auch in anderen großstädten
in kommender zeit dass zu solchen
ausschreitungen kommen wir zu solchen
krawallen ausschließen kann man das
natürlich nicht aber die polizeipräsenz
ist absolut notwendig ich fand es
richtig dass die polizei aber auch die
politik in frankfurt sehr schnell eben
auch ein sicherheits kongress einberufen
hat um zu sehen wie kann man vor ort
auch etwas tun also mit platzverweisen
das dann auch hier etwas getan wird
direkt vor ort so dass es gar nicht erst
zu so einer eskalation auch kommen kann
alkohol ist natürlich auch immer im
spiel insofern alkoholverbot in dem
zusammenhang auf öffentlichen plätzen wo
so etwas passiert ist sicherlich auch
ein entscheidender punkt aber für mich
ist wichtig wirklich die täter zu
analysieren um dann auch ganz gezielt
maßnahmen zu ergreifen leider ist es oft
heute so dass wir aus falsch
verstandenem politikern correctness
einfach zum beispiel die täter herkunft
nicht nennen das ist genau falsch damit
will man keinen unter generalverdacht
stellen sondern ganz im gegenteil nur
wenn man weiß wo es irgendwelche
probleme da sind kann man auch etwas tun
das haben wir zum beispiel in
niedersachsen beispiel aussieht dann
ganz genau so gemacht gab es viel ärger
dass wir hier direkte studien gemacht
haben aber anschließend war das von
erfolg gekrönt